but we were talking about Chess families
and Magnus himself comes from one his
dad's a chess player I've seen him play
open events as well as sisters so there
is a lot of Chess going on in the
Carlson Family and we've got the king
spawn opening David what do you make of
these first few moves and the archangels
by black yeah that's right uh early days
here I like what tabataway is doing he's
still he's chosen quite an ambitious
setup for Black uh black Bishop out
there on C5 on a really nice diagonal
and provoking black to come forward uh
he always see the white Bishop drop
Messier the more genius you are yep 100
I agree yeah not that I've seen your
room I just meant like uh but the chess
has been equally messy in this matchup
and as you mentioned David that an
ambitious approach by uh amen the bishop
coming out the dark Squad Bishop coming
out early on keeping it ahead of the
pawn chain rather than behind the pawn
chain is there any chance of black going
all out on the king side pushing Gary a
Jeep on this time breaking this pin we
see between the white dot Square bishop
and The Black Queen on the board now and
that does signal aggression we're going
to see a really imbalanced game where
black has sees space all over the board
on both flanks now black has advanced
pawns but of course still complicated I
love it but Magnus did just bring his
Knight to that square where it was
attacked so let's do a quick action
replay of the last couple of moves it
looked like a very standard position
around here uh of course white has these
doubled e-pawns but uh black has pushed
forward with g5s weakening himself
somewhat and now Magnus Knight to H4
beautiful move jumping in potentially to
an outpost if this Knight is taken it is
actually poisoned then suddenly you
would live to regret this uh this is a
deadly pin the Knight and queen hit and
this Knight is falling next move this
would end in a decisive attack against
the black king so the bait was not taken
here and uh Bishop to G4 I wouldn't be
surprised if Magnus moves the queen I
don't know where but uh Magnus he's
gonna move his Queen and there we go
Queen's E1 same idea I don't think you
can afford to trade light squared
Bishops that black Bishop is needed to
trade off for that white knight if it
ever jumps in so Amin has to just drop
his Bishop back somewhere and I hope
that Magnus cannot stir up any uh attack
in the next few moves come back to White
Black's uh position I thought it was
really risky actually I mean you oh and
there we see Bishop takes Bishop
99 problems and a bishop is one
definitely yeah that looks horrible
doesn't it I mean look at that square
what a square that that white knight is
found and you know you you might even
have some tactics here but simply this
move just seems so strong right yeah
with the Knight on F5 I mean will not
survive uh it's gonna be Checkmate
surely here I was a good move pretty
much always we did see one case we
should let down the side but obviously
you want to open up the black king
because of your fantastic White Knight
you've got a rook thinking you know
first things get in you open up the H
line and then all guns are high on that
H file
now the bishop is coming into the game
Sorry David no go on no I was just gonna
say now the bishop is introduced into
the attack I mean it's all going wrong
attacking The Rook attacking the Knight
what to do next if the Rook drops back
I mean at the very least the queen can
start coming
feels like something's lining up against
this Knight and uh yeah I mean okay he's
also playing on the other side now that
black knight only if I was actually
White's friend it's at the edge of the
board so what's the deeper concept of
actually pushing it back towards his own
King
one of the things when you are playing a
defensive type of position you know you
just got to be optimistic I mean
especially if you have such a position
like this where you're expected nine
times out of ten to lose uh that oh a
Magnus now striking in the center you go
back I go forward is what he says no you
know what I do if I was black here
go and have a nice dinner you know
takeaway maybe travel for black and with
that last one trade it looks like Magnus
has sold his Central Bond structure
problem and created another Square for
the night to retreat to to E3 uh where
you can start targeting the F7 Pawn uh
I've been shaking his head he's trying
to create some play of his own
because it looks like it's not going to
be enough the Knight falls back to G3 C3
pawns defended F7 hanging smelly yeah
it's getting worse and worse Magnus is
just slowly methodically improving his
pieces look at that the Knight and F5
was glorious but it was in the way of
White's Queen and Rook so he maneues it
takes two Tempe well spent uh to the
side of the board but attacking this F6
pawn and not even a hint of activity not
even a hint of counter play and that's
the most frustrating thing in chess when
you're putting it doesn't give you a
chance
and okay forced to retreat there we go
breakthrough wow did you see that please
he wins it's just how it goes in chess
it's conductor it's just uh
everyone just seems to be moving to his
beat all the pieces landing on the spot
this is a killer God simply walks into a
double attack the Knight Retreats that
is a fork and this would be resign time
actually this is happening right now
that pawn could not be tolerated but
black is losing material and not just
that but the pawn in the middle on F6
will fall next move as well this this
looks like it's about to finish any
moment he does fall back with the queen
and the king recaptures in G6 that's
playing with fire it's uh White having a
rook for blacks tonight in porn so
actually only technically one point down
but it's just the fact that uh well
actually another poster I think I missed
that one I was just gonna say it's just
the fact that black king is so open you
don't even need to take this Pawn you
could have gone for checkmate Magnus but
no he's just doing the maths here he's
counting collecting quite a fight by
Amin if you don't look at the scoreline
I don't think it tells the full score
story Magnus winning this taking it in
three matches the games were a lot
closer than what it seems uh if you just
take a look at the scorecard he has
played very into Point enterprising
chess and uh I think that that game one
was maybe key I mean when you get a
chance against Magnus you've got to take
it you don't generally get more than one
chance against Magnus and uh he could
have won that ending and actually taken
a lead in the match and uh obviously now
things are really bad he's hanging on
here but yeah it's not going the way he
wants and that's the thing with the top
players uh in the world some kind of
super strong Grandmasters like I mean to
about to buy they can match them step
foot by step but when it comes down to
the crunch moments that Killer Instinct
just seems to be a bit sharper with
players like Magnus Fabiano these kind
of really Elite Grand Masters they spot
everything they very rarely blunder very
rarely miss an opportunity and kind of
incrementally they seem to to rack up
the winds is over and Simon the point
that you were making that against Magnus
you don't get chances if you get that
one chance you better grab it with both
hands there we go if you want to be
really sadistic I was going to say uh
just slowly but surely now the white B
Pawn is stepping forward jump out the
way and White's Bishop indirectly hits
the black queen it doesn't matter
whether you win in 60 moves or 40 moves
and there we see Magnus pushing his Pawn
forward he's getting ready to perhaps
push the B Pawn as well and create
another passed on miniature or would you
rather win a 100 move long torture game
David Davids depends what I'm doing in
the evening
generally I'd probably like to you know
do something in the evening so give me a
bit of brutality and I will take it but
I think I know the answer to this one uh
David if you had a choice between a 20
move miniature King hunt brilliancy
Prize or let's say 150 moves to you 150
move grind eight hours later the
Guinness Book of Records oh yeah all the
restaurants are shut no bars are open
all the Arbiters are sleeping which one
would you prefer I would take a 300 move
150th rookie numbers and uh I think
we're about to see a result yeah Bishop
to E3 last movement that's it it's done
Magnus Carlsen takes the witchy I'm in
tabatabai resigns and with that
everything is over the queen is